When you turn on your Windows computer,
you're prompted with a login screen.
This is where you gain access to your
desktop and to all of the resources
associated with your account. If you're
logging in with a user that is defined
on the local computer, we refer to that
as a local account. This is the type of
account that you've configured on your
systems that you might use at home. When
you log into Windows at home, it may
prompt you to log in with your local
account. When you installed Windows, you
may have chosen to synchronize it with
your Microsoft account. This means that
you can synchronize all of these
settings between different devices and
use the same username and password
across all of those devices. And if
you're working at a business, you're
probably logging in with your domain
account. This is very similar to a
Microsoft account, but instead of the
account being managed with the Microsoft
cloud, the account is instead managed
with your local organization's Windows
domain. You'll often hear people refer
to this as logging in with their domain
login or with their Active Directory
credentials. If you'd like to see all of
the local users that are defined on your
computer, you can go to computer
management and choose the option for
local users and groups. This will
provide a list of all of the users and
all of the groups that are defined on
this local computer. Even if you've not
configured any accounts on this Windows
device, there are a few that are enabled
by default. One of these accounts is the
administrator account. That is the
account that has full access to the
system. There might also be a guest
account and most guest accounts are
usually configured to have limited
access to the operating system. And then
there might be a standard user. Here's
my user account, Professor. And that is
the normal account I would use for
logging into this Windows system. If you
click the groups tab, you'll see a large
number of groups that are enabled by
default on your Windows system. You
might recognize some of these group
names. For example, there is an
administrator group, a backup operators
group, a guest group, and there is a
power users group. Power users is a
group that's been around in Windows for
a very long time, and it was originally
designed to have some additional
capabilities over a normal user. But
these days, we don't generally use the
power users group, but it is still
included in the list for backwards
compatibility.
When you log in, you may be presented to
put in your username and your password.
These are probably the most common
authentication credentials that you'll
find, but there are other options when
you log in. You might be asked for a
personal identification number or a PIN,
and you need to input the PIN to log
into the system. There might also be
biometrics, so your device might have a
fingerprint reader, or it might perform
facial recognition with your camera. And
there could be a single sign on option,
especially if you're working in a
business because you have a Windows
domain that can allow you to log in one
time in the morning and have access to
all of the devices and resources you
need on that network without having to
put those credentials again constantly
throughout the day. One of the biggest
problems we have with authentication is
people have to put in a username and a
password. Many people might use an easy
to remember or relatively weak password
or they might not remember their
password and end up writing it down and
putting on a yellow sticky that's on
their monitor. Neither of those is a
best practice for security. So, we've
had to think about ways to make the
login process easier. One of those
methods is to use passwordless
authentication. This means we are able
to authenticate into our system, but we
don't use a password to provide that
authentication. That solves your problem
with weak passwords or passwords being
written down, but still provides
security for the people logging into
their system. You might already be using
some type of passwordless
authentication. When you start your
computer, it might do facial recognition
or it might use a security key that you
plug into a USB drive. There's also
functions within Windows called Windows
Hello, which is a series of
authentication options which may not
require a password. This may not be the
primary form of authentication. You
might have required a username and
password on your initial login, but any
subsequent loginins may be using some
type of passwordless authentication. Or
you might need to use multiple
passwordless authentication functions to
be able to log in if you're not using
your username and
password. Here's some of the options
available for passwordless
authentication in Windows using Windows
Hello. Windows Hello supports facial
recognition, fingerprint recognition, a
personal identification number, and then
you could also use a security key or a
picture password. And of course, there
is always the option to sign in with
your account's actual
password. In Windows, there are a number
of different ways to provide access to
different files and folders on our local
computer. For example, if you were to
look at the properties of a folder that
is on your system, this happens to be
one in my documents folder, and the
folder name is called reports. You can
see a number of different users that
have access to this particular folder.
And you can set up rights and
permissions for each individual user or
group. We refer to the rights and
permissions of these documents on the
local file system as NTFS permissions.
This is the NT file system permissions.
But of course, people can access a
number of those files and folders from
outside of your local computer across
the network. When you make those files
and folders available across the
network, they're referred to as a
Windows share. And there is a different
set of rights and permissions if you are
providing access through a window share
across the network. So the question then
becomes if there is a certain right and
permissions set for NTFS and a different
set of rights and permissions for a
share permission which one of those wins
in Windows the most restrictive setting
wins. So if any of these files or
folders have been set to deny that will
override any other allow settings. Also
keep in mind that your NTFS permissions
apply to all of the files and folders
underneath that particular setting. For
example, I might have many other folders
underneath the reports folder, and I
might add new files into the reports
folder at any time. These NTFS
permissions that I've created for the
reports folder will also apply to all of
the folders underneath the reports
folder and to all of the files that I
add at any time into the reports folder.
The only time this is different is if
you move a file into this folder from
the same volume. If you move a file or
folder on that same volume, it keeps the
original
permissions. Let's look at the
difference between the NTFS permissions
that we have on the left and the share
permissions that we have on the right
for the same folder which is the users
professor documents reports folder. On
our local machine, we have an everyone
group and in that everyone group, we
provided full access to that particular
folder. So, anyone on this local device
is able to have full control, which
includes modify, read and execute, list
folder contents, read and write
permissions. If someone was to connect
to this folder from across the network,
they would be using the share
permissions along with those NTFS
permissions. But notice that the share
permissions do not provide the same type
of permissions as the NTFS permissions.
Notice that the share permissions have
read access for everyone, but it does
not have change or full control. That
means if somebody logs in locally to
this computer, they have full access to
the reports folder. But if they connect
to the reports folder from across the
network using the share permissions,
they only have read access.
When you are configuring specific
permissions for a folder, we refer to
that as explicit permissions. This means
you have selected a specific resource
and you have configured rights and
permissions for that specific resource.
But it is possible that other files and
folders that are in the file system
could also take those same rights and
permissions. For example, if you have
additional child folders within that
single parent folder, all of the child
folders will inherit the permissions
that you set for that parent. This means
if we have a music folder that contains
individual folders for separate artists,
we can set permissions for the music
folder and those permissions will be
propagated down through all of the child
folders. Anytime you are manually
configuring explicit permissions, those
will take priority over anything that
may have been inherited. So, let's say
we've set up a music folder, but we've
configured it with no access for anyone
else. And of course, in Windows, all of
the child folders will inherit that same
configuration that we set on the music
folder. If we then manually go into the
music folder and we explicitly change
one of those, it no longer has the
inherited permissions and it now takes
the explicit permissions that we've
defined for that single
folder. As a Windows user, you have
access to run applications, start your
browser, close out different
applications, and shut down your system.
But there may be certain tasks that
require additional rights and
permissions. For example, if you're
editing a system file, installing a new
application, or modifying a service, you
might need administrator rights. To be
able to use these administrator rights
and permissions, you need to specify
that you'd like to use them. Even if
your user account has been added to the
administrators group, you still must
explicitly say that you want to use the
administrator to run a particular
application. The way that you would run
an application as an administrator is
you would right mouseclick on the name
of the application and choose the option
to run as
administrator. On my Windows machine, I
can go down to the search, type in cmd.
This brings up the command prompt. And
you can see the options to run the
command prompt are to open it or to run
as administrator. There are also other
options in here to open the file
location, pin to start, and pin to
taskbar. You can also right mouse click
on the icon itself and you have the same
options available to run as
administrator and the
others. One of the reasons that we don't
want someone always using their account
as the administrator is because
malicious software can take advantage of
those elevated rights and permissions.
But we still need a way to make changes
to our system throughout the day. One of
the ways that Windows provides this is
through user account control or UAC. If
you're running with your normal user
account and you access resources across
the network or modify the profile
settings for your account, you don't
need any type of elevated rights or
permissions. But if you begin to install
applications or services or you want to
make changes to a Windows system
application, you may require
administrator access. One of the ways
that Windows can provide you with that
elevated access is through the user
account control. Windows account control
can be manually configured to always
notify you for any of these prompts or
to never provide any UAC prompts on your
screen. When you get a UAC prompt, it
will put a box like this on your screen
that says, "Do you want to allow this
app to make changes to your device?" And
you'll either need to be part of the
administrators group or you'll need to
provide administrator credentials to be
able to perform this task. One of the
things that security professionals are
always concerned about is someone
gaining access to the data that might be
on your storage drive. This might be
especially true with things like laptops
and mobile devices that can be taken
anywhere and very often can be lost or
stolen. One of the ways that you can
prevent somebody from gaining access to
the data that's on that device is to use
some type of full disk encryption or
FDE. In Windows, full disk encryption is
enabled through the use of Bit Locker.
Bit Locker will encrypt an entire
volume, including the operating system,
all of your personal files, and anything
else you store on that volume. This
means if you lose your laptop and
somebody does gain access to that
storage device, they would not be able
to access or understand anything on that
storage device because all of the
contents have been encrypted. Even if
they were to remove your hard drive or
your SSD from a laptop and plug it into
a different computer, they still would
not have access to all of this encrypted
data. There's also similar Bit Locker
functionality available for USB flash
drives. This is called Bit Locker to Go,
and it will encrypt all of your data on
that very small flash drive. This means
if you lose the flash drive and somebody
does find it, they will not have access
to any of your encrypted
data. Instead of encrypting the entire
volume, you also have the option for
just encrypting a series of files or
folders. This is done in the file system
of Windows itself. And we call this the
encrypting file system. If you're
running NTFS as the file system, you'll
see this option when you look at the
attributes for a file or a folder. This
is available in all Windows editions
except the home editions, and it uses
your username and password to provide
the security that's used for the
encryption. If you forget your password
or somebody administratively resets the
password on that system, then you will
lose access to all of that encrypted
data. So, it's important to always have
a backup of your system so that you
never lose access to any of this
important data.